[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire mercredi dernier les
syndicats de police sont appelés à
manifester contre les violences dont les
policiers sont victimes
cela s'est passé devant l'assemblée
nationale où le garde des sceaux eric
dupond moretti était en train de
défendre sa réforme de la justice les
policiers ont reçu ce jour là le soutien
du ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin et de quantité de politique
fabien roussel du parti communiste
olivier faur du parti socialiste yannick
jadot d'europe écologie les verts jordan
bardella du rassemblement national dit
que la dupont aignan debout la france
xavier bertrand valérie pécresse laurent
wauquiez eric ciotti des républicains
dopés par les sondages qui placent la
sécurité parmi les principales
préoccupations des français les
politiques se livrent depuis quelques
temps à une véritable surenchère en
faveur de la police chacune vôtre est
une émission mais c'est une phrase du
patron du syndicat alliance qui fait
débat depuis une semaine le problème de
la police et la justice a déclaré ce
jour là
fabien vanhemelryck et pour continuer
d'en débattre car demain c'est le
beauvau de la sécurité qui reprend nous
avons invité des vidéos reverdy
secrétaire national province du syndicat
alliance police nationale des syndicats
organisateurs de la manifestation devant
l'assemblée du 19 mai dernier c'est
votre secrétaire général dont qui a
prononcé ce jour là la fameuse phrase le
problème de la police et la justice vous
êtes d'accord avec cette phrase bien
évidemment que nous sommes d'accord nous
la maintenons et nous la soutenons à
3000% et on espère que justement cette
phrase choc aujourd'hui fait débat
suscite le débat ça fait une semaine
qu'elle a été prononcée et ont j'en
espère que ce débat nourri aboutir à
quelque chose de concret pour la
protection des policiers et via une cire
marin vous êtes magistrat de président
de la chambre sociale de la cour d'appel
de versailles vous avez présidé le
syndicat de la magistrature de 2000 à
2002 fait partie des magistrats qui ont
été choquées par la phrase du patron
d'allianz pourquoi qu'est ce qu'elle est
choquante cette phrase est là d' el hadj
choquant le fait que la justice et la
police
et institutions évidemment nécessaire à
la république et que comme l'a dit le
conseil constitutionnel très très
récemment à propos de la la loi sécurité
globale qui vient d'être votée le
travail de la justice
c'est de contrôler la police donc je
pense que le contrôle des libertés
individuelles qui exerce la justice afin
du respect des libertés individuelles
individuel kiser ce la justice notamment
sur la police n'est pas un problème
c'est une obligation constitutionnelle
alain bauer vous êtes professeur de
criminologie au conservatoire national
des arts et métiers mais aussi à new
york et à shanghai il a publié de
nombreux livres sur la police et le
crime
le dernier en revanche c'est comment
vivre au temps du chrono virus un manuel
pour comprendre et résister coécrit avec
roger dachez zoo aux éditions du cerf
le problème de la police et la justice
qu'est-ce que vous inspire cette phrase
à vous ben moi je crois que le problème
de la police et de la justice ces
législateurs parce qu'à force
d'injonction contradictoires de
complications multi de retournement de
position en fonction des événements de
deux postures aussi en fonction des
tragédies qui sont réelles régulièrement
le législateur renforce le chaos et la
complication puis s'étonnent de la
lenteur des procédures se surprend à
découvrir soudain ce qu'il a voté quand
s'est mis en application
et pas plus les policiers que les
magistrats ne sont responsables des
lourdeurs des incohérences et des
complications de la procédure
donc je crois que justice et police
ferait mieux de se regrouper pour
discuter véritablement de ce qu'on n'a
jamais fait en france quasiment depuis
50 ans c'est une conférence de politique
pénale qui viserait à savoir ce qu'on
veut comme elle veut et pourquoi on le
veut et de cesser de vouloir tout et son
contraire en fonction des événements
michel kokoreff si vous êtes sociologue
professeur à l'université paris 8
chercheur au centre de recherches
sociologiques et politiques de paris
vous êtes l'auteur de refaire la cité
avec didier lapeyronnie sts est paru au
seuil et de violences policières
généalogique
violence d'état aux éditions textuel
alors pour vous le problème de la police
et la justice
manifestement on a vu réapparaître ce
fantasme de la justice laxiste
bon c'est un thème qui apparaît au moins
depuis le début des années 80 avec les
attaques quand vis-à-vis de l'ain du
laxisme de la gauche en matière de
culture sécuritaire bon moi ce qui me
frappe c'est pas tant que les
organisations professionnelles appellent
leurs adhérents à se mobiliser sur les
conditions de travail ou en hommage au
décès de l'un des leurs
mais avec matt sont mais ce qui est
frappant c'est qu'effectivement c'est la
tournure très politique voire
législatives de ces de ses
revendications et qu'il ne résiste pas à
l'épreuve des faits c'est surtout ça qui
est qui est frappant et qui permet quand
même de parler d'idéologie c'est que
quand on regarde on y reviendra sans
doute les données statistiques par
exemple le dernier rapport d'hélène
cazaux charles qui était directrice de
linde ges on voit bien que il ya même
une sorte de sueur pénalisation des
auteurs d'agressions des forces de
l'ordre et d'autres données statistiques
montrent que de laxisme
il n'y a pas et que les les auteurs
encore une fois notamment de
d'agressions à l'égard des forces de
l'ordre sont plutôt plus poursuivis plus
rapidement plus plus sévèrement que les
auteurs d'autres d'autres violences donc
semblerait que la justice soit le
problème de la police
mais au sens plutôt idéologique du terme
alors justement là la justice laxiste
on pourrait peut-être commencer par ça
puisque c'est c'est un peu ce qu'on a
entendu depuis une semaine
en quoi la justice était laxiste à vos
yeux david aurait vernis à plusieurs et
plusieurs égards j'ai envie de dire que
ce n'est pas un fantasme qu'on vienne me
le dire votre précédente interlocuteur
souvenez vous en mai 2020 une circulaire
de madame la garde des sceaux nicole
belloubet demander au procureur de faire
attention avant de mettre quelqu'un en
prison pour savoir s'il y avait de la
place
souvenez vous le 3 juin 2020 monsieur
dupont moretti qui parlait alors qu'il
était encore avocat qu'il fallait
réduire la population carcérale que ce
n'était ni déraisonnable dits dangereux
et qu' il appelait à tout mettre en
oeuvre pour que cette population
carcérale ne reporte pas ne repartent
pas pardon à la hausse à l'issue donc
des périodes qu'ovide et plus près de
nous au mois de octobre 2020 ce monsieur
moretti devenu garde des sceaux nous
indiquer qu' il fallait que les
magistrats est une réponse pénale est
extrêmement rapide par rapport à la date
des faits et qui sous-entendu si la peau
la prison n'était pas possible parce que
les dates d'audience étaient trop
éloignées il fallait trouver des
alternatives à la poursuite ces
alternatives à la poursuite il les a
répétés et lors d'une circulaire de
politique pénale
il y a pas longtemps et et tout ça en
même temps il a également rappelé les
magistrats lors d'une circulaire du 4
novembre de l'année dernière à être plus
ferme
sous-entendu qu'il ne l'était pas face
aux agresseurs des forces de l'ordre
donc en fait ce n'est pas un fantasme
c'est une ré c'est une réalité
et pour illustrer cette réalité juste un
exemple un policier attaqué au cocktail
molotov
il manque d'être brûlé qu'a dit la
justice
l'auteur est condamné à un stage de
citoyenneté un stage de citoyenneté pour
avoir lancé des cocktails molotov sur
des policiers
un autre exemple près à grigny en
ile-de-france un refus d'obtempérer me
denjean imminente de mise en danger de
la vie d'autrui recel de vol de véhicule
un policier gravement blessé 180 jours
d'itt et et 180 jours d'itt été avec des
séquelles graves
réponse de la justice une admonestation
une admonestation vous entendez bien une
admonestation parce que l'auteur est
mineure donc la police le problème de la
police c'est effectivement la justice et
d'une certaine partie de la justice mais
comme l'a dit monsieur bauer également
des politiques qui par des injonctions
complètement contradictoire met un petit
peu la pagaille dans tout ça et c'est
assez catastrophique alors réponse de
dévier un tir bas rhin oui et côté c'est
l'état l'éternel et gréements des
décisions qui ne plaisent pas ni aux uns
ni aux autres ni aux policiers ont de
toute façon c'est le travail ordinaire
des juges de ne plaire à personne dans
un procès alors ce qui est dit là c'est
que apparemment les peu les agressions
de policiers sont ne sont pas assez puni
ou pas puni bon premièrement alors ça
c'est faux je crois que et alain bauer
et michel kokoreff le meut corrigeront
mai
les statistiques montrent que plus
depuis 10 ans tout ce qui est agréé sion
contre des policiers
en fait les condamnations et les peines
ont doublé on est à peu près à 30000
condamnation par an et y compris les
outrages et rébellion qui se sont
vraiment multipliaient l'onssa a doublé
aussi le nombre de condamnations
ça c'est du point de vue statistique
c'est donc totalement faux mais on ne
peut pas empêcher de citer des exemples
qui peuvent avoir choqué certains
policiers
ce que je voulais dire deuxièmement
c'est moi ça me surprend toujours que la
justice soit le mauvais objet comme ça
parce que nous avons effectivement en
gros les mêmes difficultés et ce qu'il
faudrait c'est se poser les questions
sur l'organisation même de la police moi
j'ai pas vraiment entendu ça pendant les
manifestations parle beaucoup de moyens
c'est pas uniquement la question des
moyens de la police et la justice c'est
pareil c'est aussi à quoi sert des
policiers est ce que les policiers ça
sert à faire du chiffre
il ya une politique du chiffre depuis
très longtemps est ce que par exemple
relevé des infractions des usages de
stupéfiant est-ce que c'est utile que la
police fasse alors ça fait beaucoup
évidemment de de travail d'infractions
constatées mais est-ce que c'est utile
et puis je pense qu'on en parlera
pendant votre émission tout le problème
pour les juges de formation des
policiers qui font tout ce qu'ils
peuvent sur le terrain et avec lesquels
c'est très curieux parce que la parole
des syndicats ne correspond pas du tout
au ressenti des magistrats sur le
terrain parce qu'on n'a pas de problème
avec la police judiciaire alors les
policiers parce qu'on voit au niveau de
la justice c'est que souvent les
policiers ne sont pas suffisamment
formés et qu' il ya quand même pas mal
de nullité de procédure qui font que
parfois et bien évidemment on aboutit à
des relaxes ont abouti à des non lieux
mais c'est pas uniquement ça c'est toute
l'organisation de la police
le recrutement s'est multiplié c'est sûr
mais au niveau de la police judiciaire
par exemple nous n'avons pas assez de
policiers de police judiciaire et ça
c'est quelque chose qui est très gênant
pour la justice pour finir je conviens
tout à fait que les délais de jugement
sont beaucoup trop lents mais là on en
revient vraiment un problème de moyens
je donne un seul exemple on parle
beaucoup en ce moment de violence
conjugale est malheureusement de
meurtres de femmes et on voit bien que
si les juges des affaires familiales
mettait moins de temps à rendre des
décisions parce qu'ils sont pas assez
nombreux et bien pendant la période très
difficile d'une séparation d'un divorce
etc ou là les risques de violences
conjugales sont toujours très importants
s'il y avait un délai moindre je pense
qu'on aurait beaucoup moins de violence
conjugale mais c'est un problème là
d'organisation et de moyens de la
justice
et je pense que pour la police c'est
absolument la même chose quel dommage
d'opposer sans arrêt ces deux corps qui
en réalité rencontre bien souvent les
mêmes problèmes
on a vu depuis une semaine à portraits
notamment à la bouche des politiques
mais pas seulement dans les médias aussi
la police ce serait le bien le bras armé
du bien contre le mal
son seul défaut ce serait d'être mal
entouré alors elle serait mal entouré à
la fois par pas les responsables
politiques les législateurs comme disait
un labeur et puis par par le système
judiciaire qui trahirait constamment la
police c'est comme ça que vous le voyez
un labeur
moi je suis pas politicien donc ce
regard là de commentateurs des postures
des uns et des autres mais diffère
beaucoup je crois que ce qui sera
intéressant parce que ça m'arrive assez
régulièrement de me parler par exemple
avec les policiers des bac
les policiers de la sécurité publique
c'est aussi de charente compte que 95 %
de l'activité judiciaire
elle est faite par la sécurité publique
et la gendarmerie départementale pas par
les offices centraux de police
judiciaire et il faut faire attention à
ne pas se tromper de la relation en
général
excellente qui existent au niveau des
grandes
affaire judiciaire avec des magistrats
extrêmement fort mais structuré qui ont
l'habitude d'une coopération quasiment
permanente avec les enquêteurs et les
dures réalités du terrain de la sécurité
publique et du maintien de l'ordre au
quotidien de la sécurité du quotidien ou
là la confrontation est d'une tout autre
nature l'incompréhension aussi est d'une
tout autre nature entre l'injonction du
maintien de la tranquillité publique et
celle de la nécessité de l'ordre public
il ya un choix qui a été fait je me
rappelle à nouveau il n'est pas fait par
les policiers les gendarmes ou les
magistrats les alternatives c'est pas
eux qui ont fait la loi
les circulaires pesnel elle s'applique
sur une législation et de ce point de
vue là gouvernements de droite comme
gouvernement de gauche ont été marqués
par une posture qui est de toutes les
dispositions possibles et imaginables
avant une sanction
or notre code pénal ces prisons pour
tous et pour tous comme ça n'est pas
possible on a établi toute une série de
dispositifs plus ou moins adaptés et qui
ont abouti essentiellement à ralentir et
à rallonger le processus du coup à
alourdir les peines car le paradoxe de
cette affaire c'est que jamais on a été
aussi lent mais jamais on a été aussi
sévère et du coup au lieu d'être dans un
dispositif de on a toujours le droit à
une deuxième chance et c'est raisonnable
de considérer ça parce que
criminologique mans parlant sur cent
prime aux auteurs 70 ne recommence
jamais
donc même le rappel à la loi dont on
parle beaucoup ces temps ci est assez
efficace
par contre il y en a 30 % qu'on ne peut
pas identifier à la première infraction
mais qu'on identifie à la deuxième qui
eux pose un certain nombre de problèmes
et en fonction de la gravité de ces
infractions le système ne peut pas dire
deuxième chance troisième chance
quatrième chance cinquième champ sixième
chance 10e chance 20e chance 30e chante
parce que ça serait pas assez grave pas
assez important ou que cela menacerait
la tranquillité publique et l'injonction
contradicteurs elle est dans
l'incapacité à interroger la réalité de
ce qu'est une procession un processus
pénal une politique pénale et on ne peut
pas faire la politique pénale sans les
policiers
et chants les juges pour l'instant on
l'a fait sans eux et ensuite on leur
demande de se débrouiller avec
mais si michel kokoreff oui alors je ne
sais pas comment reprendre la question
mais comme pour moi les faits sont têtus
et que ça me semble important je voulais
quand même revenir sur cette cette
histoire de laxisme et notamment à
l'égard des agresseurs des forces de
l'ordre forces de l'ordre comprenant
police nationale et gendarmerie et je
prends comme exemple ce rapport de 2016
parce qu'il a été fait par quelqu'un de
la maison donc d'une certaine manière il
peut avoir une certaine crédibilité
qu'est ce qu'ils disent ce rapport bah
il dit notamment que le taux de réponse
pénale à l'encontre des auteurs de
violences commises contre les forces de
sécurité et 2 96% soit 13 points de plus
que le taux de réponse au pénal aux
violences qui sont commises contre les
personnes qui sont non dépositaires de
l'autorité de l'autorité publique bon
lorsque l'auteur est mineur lorsque
l'auteur de ces agressions contre les
forces de l'ordre des mineurs est bien
le taux de réponse pénale s'élève à 97 %
contre 91% pour les autres violences ça
c'est un premier ensemble de données
motif effectivement permet quand même de
douter de l'absence de ses vérités sur
un contentieux qui a mobilisé et à juste
titre on le comprend après le décès d'un
policier
les syndicats il ya un deuxième chiffre
qui est aussi intéressant c'est que
et c'est de ce sont des chiffres qui
sont plus récents qui date de 2010 9 qui
sont fournis par les ministères de la
justice et qui montre que ce taux de
réponse pénale s'est maintenue dans des
proportions comparables dans les années
suivantes
c'est à dire qu'il était à 94 % en 2016
et à 2018 ils étaient à 95% en 2019 est
donc toujours au dessus des autres types
de de violence est entourée comme ça
continue et sur les condamnations en
constatant que les condamnations en
correctionnelle pour violences sur
personne dépositaire de dépositaire de
l'autorité publique est en augmentation
c'est à dire que en 2008 on comptait
4415 condamnation dix ans après on en
comptait 5840 donc quand même une
augmentation presque de 2 20%
alors est-ce que si les procès sont au
rendez-vous les sanctions sont serait
trop trop légère et là encore on voit
bien au regard des données dont on
dispose pas ce qu'on peut pas raisonner
je suis désolé sur un exemple tiré de je
ne sais pas où
isolé de son contexte or donc si on
considère les choses de façon un peu
plus sérieuse
on remarque que les peines prononcées
pour violences contre les forces de
sécurité sont dans plus de 75% des cas
des peines d'emprisonnement avec ou sans
sursis
et même lorsque le policier ou le
gendarme ne subit pas d'incapacité de
travail
donc au moins sur ce plan là on peut pas
dire que la justice n'est pas laxiste
mais si on prend d'autres contentieux je
connais un peu pour les avoir étudiés
comme le contentieux des stupéfiants et
bien ce que l'on constate depuis les
années 2000 je renvoie aux enquêtes
excellente de l'observatoire français
des drogues et des toxicomanies que on
assiste à une sur pénalisation de l'usaj
deux produits stupéfiants avec une
festivement une tendance à la baisse
voire à la disparition des classements
sans suite bon et toute façon la
fraction cette procédure de classement a
disparu bon mais les peines alternatives
régressent et par contre dans un grand
nombre de cas sur une dizaine d'années
de 2010 à 2020 on constate une plutôt
une sur pénalisation des
des usages donc effectivement ce qui est
intéressant de constater c'est que d'un
côté il ya cette accusation d'une jeff
d'une justice qui serait qui serait
laxiste mais d'un autre côté on voit
bien que pour les victimes de violences
policières
c'est à dire d'intervention qui
occasionne dans des circonstances non
élucidées
la mort de personnes qui sont
interpellés et bien dans ces situations
là on voit bien que il n'y a pas de
réponse pénale que les classements sans
suite ou les non lieux sont la règle
font jurisprudence
depuis depuis les années 70 bon donc
voyez la justice n'est pas forcément la
même pour tous bons et je voudrais
ajouter un dernier point par rapport à
ce qui a été dit peut-être que de la
même manière que le problème des
policiers c'est les conditions de
travail
c'est la formation et j'espère qu'on va
en parler parce que les policiers ne
sont pas formés pour faire le boulot
qu'ils font
il faut arrêter de dire n'importe quoi
bon de la même manière les services de
justice les magistrats ne prennent pas
leur temps ils sont surchargés et peu
dotées en moyens
c'est ça la réalité dans les
commissariats les conditions de travail
le manque de moyens bon et auquel on ne
répond pas par des anathèmes idéologique
et en même temps dans parmi les
parquetiers où les les magistrats est
effectivement avec le contentieux des
violences conjugales ou des féminicides
est tout à fait significatif et on voit
bien la lenteur et surtout
le peu de condamnations qui existent au
pénal je parle pas des condamnations
morales donc je pense qu'effectivement
il faut reprendre un peu raison garder
raison et reprendre les problèmes à bras
le corps mais de façon quand même un peu
plus pragmatique que politique avec le
soutien des ministres ou pas alors david
et or avait re div
oui alors je voudrais pas compte mais
prennent les taux de réponse pénale
comme le deal a égrainé monsieur sont
effectivement extraordinaire dans ce
pays 96 97 % de réponses pénales donc
quand on entend ça on a tout dit mais
surtout on n'a rien dit pourquoi parce
qu'on parle de quelle réponse finale
dans les deux exemples que je vous ai
cités tout à l'heure donc une
admonestation un stage de citoyenneté
c'est une réponse pénale aujourd'hui
vous avez une affaire sur cinq qui est
présenté à la justice qui correspond ou
qui correspondait parce que c'est fini
un rappel à la loi
une affaire sur cinq qui ne correspond
quasiment à rien vous avez effectivement
des peines de prison monsieur a raison
les peines de prison ont augmenté il ya
132 mille peines de prison qui ont été
donnés en 2010 neuf cent trente deux
mille peines mais il n'ya que 60000
places de prison ça veut dire que les
peines de prison que l'on donne ne sont
pas effectués
c'est pour ça que nous le syndicat
alliance on a demandé la création d'un
observatoire de la réponse pénale de
manière à ce que l'on puisse comparer
entre eux les peines encourues
les peines prononcées par les magistrats
et surtout les peines réellement
effectués et c'est sur l'effectivité de
la peine que pour nous il ya réellement
ce problème donc on peut nous aider nous
donner tous les chiffres qu'on veut que
la justice serait forte que la justice
serait impartiale et qu'elle passerait
par tous et qu'elle serait j'allais dire
vivant vigoureuse en attendant
l'effectivité de la peine
on le voit la réponse pénale est forte
mais de quelles réponses pénales parle
parle parle on nous et c'est là où le
bât blesse
et c'est là où nous policiers nous avons
des tonnes et des tonnes d'exemples au
quotidien comme l'a dit monsieur alain
bauer
ce n'est pas sur le haut du spectre la
délinquance que
l'histoire se jugent elles se jouent sur
la délinquance du quotidien refuge
surtout les faits qui pourrissent la vie
de nos collègues et elle pourrit sur
tous les faits qui aujourd'hui dans sont
victimes nos collègues plus de 30
blessés au quotidien par jour dans ce
pays
ce chiffre ne cesse d'augmenter pourquoi
parce qu'aujourd'hui la violence et
désinhibée dans ce pays
et plus personne n'a peur de s'en
prendre à un policier surtout quand
derrière il a comme sanction un stage de
citoyenneté ou une admonestation de la
part du magistrat donc oui il ya un
problème il faut le dire il faut en
parler et il faut que ça cesse
monsieur dupont moretti d'ailleurs l'a
reconnu dans différentes circulaire
parce que sinon il n'aurait pas pris la
peine d'écrire aux magistrats pour leur
demander de la fermeté contre ceux qui
agressent les policiers parce que dit-il
derrière ceux qui agressent les
policiers on s'en prend à l'état et à
l'autorité de l'état
donc en fait le constat est bien posée
sauf que la réalité pratique est tout
autre et c'est ça le problème
et c'est pour ça que le problème de la
police je le répète c'est réellement la
justice pas tous les magistrats pas par
global it et de tout ça mais la manière
dont est rendu la justice dans ce pays
pose problème et et on en est victime au
quotidien dans nos chairs et et ça c'est
inacceptable qu'on fait une pause on se
retrouve juste après on continue ce
débat
[Musique]
après six mois de fermeture commerce non
essentiels terrasse ou encore cinéma ont
rouvert leurs portes le 19 mai lors
forcément le redémarrage peut parfois
être laborieux déjà on boit beaucoup
d'endroits de retrouver les équipes de
reprendre un rythme avec en plus des
restrictions qui sont délicates pour
travailler correctement les projections
de croissance etc c'est exceptionnel
on a eu je doute qu'elles soient
réalisées aussi facilement que ça il va
falloir quand même avoir une vision de
relation d'accompagnement que plus
grande
on navigue presque un petit peu a vu
quand les aides vont s'arrêter
il est assez probable que ça fasse
beaucoup de dégâts parce qu'on va voir
le deuxième coup fatal derrière et un
autre confinement septembre tordre
serait dramatique pour la profession et
moralement le terrible où on nous vend
du rêve et malheureusement ça se
transforme vite en cauchemar
[Musique]
si demain d'un conflit ouvert ce produit
entre la chine et les usa
on peut penser il se déroulera dans la
mer de chine du sud
car cette zone est totalement
stratégique pour les deux ans en 2019
la chine a construit en une année on
paie plus de bâtiments que les états
unis en quatre ans guerre de 1941 à 1940
en affichant ainsi sa souveraineté en
mer de chine du sud
pékin fait prévaloir des droits dits
historiques sur les règles
internationales
quand une puissance dominante constate
qu'elle est en train de se faire
dépasser par une puissance émergente la
tentation normale et de la détruire au
plan politique ou militaire avant
qu'elle n'arrive à 6 fin
[Musique]
on reprend notre débat avec david or
verdi du syndicat alliance police
nationale avec evelyne sire martin qui
est magistrate alain bauer qui est
professeur de criminologie michel
kokoreff qui est sociologue david
reverdy viens de citer quelques chiffres
je m'en parler avec l abord parce que
gérald darmanin a dit qu'il préférait le
ressenti d'un boucher charcutier de de
tourcoing aux statistiques de l'insee
mais jetez vous à l'abord que vous avez
le respect des chiffres alors justement
il y en a certains qui ont circulé
depuis une semaine
j'aimerais que veut me disais ce que
vous en pensez les le risque de pour les
policiers de d'être tués au travail
aurait été divisée par quatre en 30 ans
et par deux en vingt ans est ce que vous
le confirmer alors c'est grosso modo
exact mais ça subi les mouvements
erratiques qui vont de 40 à 12 qui
remonte à 20 qu'il redescende
et il se trouve que il faut prendre en
considération ce que je répète assez
souvent c'est qu'en la matière les
homicides sont une chose les tentatives
d'homicides en sont une autre les coups
et blessure volontaire pouvant entraîner
la mort
il ya un cet indicateur qui permettent
de voir ça à peu près depuis 50 ans
d'ailleurs et qui montrent plutôt une
certaine dégradation globale de ce que
j'appelle l'homicide it et tout ce qui
vise à donner la mort même si ça ne
réussit pas mais en terme d' assassinats
de policiers en service et surtout en
mission policiers et gendarmes
d'ailleurs je précise que la mortalité
des gendarmes ne doit pas être
sous-estimé à jeu je dis ça parce que il
ya une sorte d' équilibre voire même un
peu plus de gendarmes tués dans
l'exercice de fos et de leurs fonctions
que deux policiers
il y a des effets et on est plutôt sur
une remontée après avoir connu une une
baisse relativement sensible deuxième et
manque je voudrais indiquer c'est que il
faut toujours se méfier des indicateurs
à 90%
ils sont trop soviétique pour être
honnête et donc le taux de réponse
pénale n'est absolument pas ce qui en
dit le taux de réponse pénale est
d'abord un taux de non réponses pénales
je voudrais mettre en garde contre
l'usagé de cet indicateur falsifiés et
statistiquement inégale voilà il ya 5
millions d'affaires pénales qui
parviennent chaque année au parquet 5
millions 40 un peu plus de 40% compte un
auteur donc on peut pas reprocher à la
police à la justice pardon de ne pas
poursuivre des gens qu'elle n'a peu
qu'ils n'ont pas été identifiés il reste
environ 2,1 millions d'auteurs dont 600
milles en vue leur affaire classée sans
suite et ensuite seulement on calcule le
taux de réponse alors si le taux de
réponse et par rapport à la victimation
il est très faible si les par rapport
aux ensembles des faits arrivée il est
faible
si les par rapport au nombre d'auteurs
connus il est beaucoup moins
impressionnant qu'il n'ait est
effectivement dans ce taux de réponse
pénale il ya tout et n'importe quoi y
compris des alternatives dont je ne mets
pas en doute l'importance sauf qu'en
france on cumule les alternatives on a
les alternatives aux poursuites et les
alternatives open et ensuite on a un
problème d'exécution ou d'une exécution
des peines et je précise que dans tout
ce dispositif c'est le législateur qui a
inventé ce processus pas les magistrats
que le choix de la peine peut relever de
leurs responsabilités puisque ils sont
souvent seuls à en décider notamment
dans les comparutions immédiates
mais ce qu'on a découvert depuis la mise
en place des comparutions immédiates
notamment
c'est une arrivée beaucoup plus massive
en prison qu'avant c'est à dire que les
flux d'entrée en prison on se sont
accélérées ce qui explique le surplus
d'entrer dans les prisons est donc ce
qu'on croit être du laxisme dans
l'absence des poursuites se traduit
quand il y as poursuit et décision de
prison d'un alourdissement de la peine
c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ce
qu'il y paraît il faut être très prudent
avec l'outil statistique d'abord il faut
le compléter par des sources
complémentaires
mais un élément reste indiscutable c'est
que tous les indicateurs sur les
agressions de pompiers les agressions de
médecins et d agressions d'infirmières
les agressions de magistrats les
agressions d'agents publics les
agressions de postiers les agressions de
gaziers
les agressions d'instituteurs les
agressions d'enseignants se sont
extraordinairement développer les
agressions à l'intérieur des services
d'urgence et que quand on récupère
l'ensemble de ces outils
ce qui était la mission de
l'observatoire national de la
délinquance et des réponses pénales que
le gouvernement précédent a trouvé
intelligent de supprimer et donc de
l'avant de l'annoncé qu'il allait leur
créer parce que bien évidemment
l'incohérence amène toujours à des
punitions en tout cas je parle en terme
d'opinion et je salue l'action des
syndicats qui réclament le retour de cet
observatoire parce que au moins il
donnait des éléments de vérité et de
réalité et surtout de contexte sur les
chiffres puisque david et reverdy viens
de parler du nombre de policiers blessés
on a beaucoup dit aussi cette semaine
que dans le dans le compte des policiers
blessés on ne faisait pas la différence
entre un policier qui s'était blessé
tordu la cheville en service un qui
avait reçu un pavé 1 sur qui on avait
tiré à balles réelles vous le confirmer
alain bauer tout ça c'est des blessés
des policiers des stups une fiche sur
agent peut blesser en service qui
détaille très exactement ce que sont les
le service par exemple un accident en
allant au travail ou en revenant du
travail et la confrontation avec un
agresseur y compris le fait d'être tué
par un automobiliste qui refuse de
s'arrêter le refus d'obtempérer est un
élément qu'il faut absolument pas
sous-estimer ça concerne beaucoup les
gendarmes d'ailleurs ou qui se fait
tirer dessus ou comme il a été indiqué
tout à l'heure
l'envoi d'un cocktail molotov sur un
policier un gendarme un crs ou gendarmes
mobiles est un acte qui relève en ce qui
me concerne d'une intention criminelle
et qui doit être considéré comme tel qui
entrent dans l'outil statistique ça fait
une dizaine d'années que justement dans
les fiches de l'ex observatoire il y a
des indications très précises sur ces
questions est comme ça a été indiqué
tout à l'heure les refus d'obtempérer
les refus refus de s'arrêter à un
contrôle etc ont beaucoup augmenté et je
je vais dans le sens de ce que disait
madame sire-marin tout à l'heure donc il
ya une dégradation de la relation
sociale mais l'indicateur qui me paraît
le plus intéressant et qui confirme tout
à fait cette dégradation
c'est les agressions de pompiers parce
que je ne contrôle pas les identités ne
sont pas supposés maltraiter les gens
éventuellement avoir des idées du faciès
il sauve tout le monde
ils ont une mission de service public
est de sauver les gens ils sont de plus
en plus agressés donc cet indicateur la
lisa éclairer ce qui est en train d'être
dit sur beaucoup de professions dont les
policiers mais je précise aussi que les
magistrats ne sont pas les derniers à
être insultés et agressés y compris à
l'intérieur des salles d'audience donc
ils savent très bien ce qu'est cette
dégradation d'une violence qui vient au
sens social du terme et qu'il faut pas
sous-estimer et 25 martin on a entendu
beaucoup de deux politiques depuis la
manifestation de mercredi dernier
surenchérir alors dans le sécuritaire
mais aussi demandé est ce que les
policiers soient est un droit de regard
sur les peines alors olivier faure a
rétropédalé ensuite il a regretté ce
qu'il avait dit pays l'avait dit
carrément qu'il fallait qu'ils aient un
droit de regard sur les peines infligées
quand il avait été victime d'une
agression
voilà on dirait que beaucoup voudraient
que les policiers disent au magistrat un
peu ce qu'ils doivent faire
est ce que vous l'avez ressenti comme
tel et qu'est ce que vous leur répondez
alors je voudrais relever ce qu'a dit
monsieur du syndicat alliance parce que
je trouve que c'est tout à fait
symptomatique
hinault dit je maintiens le problème de
la police et la justice bon on va pas
polémiquer des heures là dessus moi je
dirais que alliance devrait dire aussi
et le législateur parce que finalement
dans le discours d'alliances et de
certains politiques on voit que la seule
peine possible c'est la peine de prison
tous les exemples qui sont pris c'est
pour nous dire toutes les autres peines
par exemple un travail d'intérêt général
ou pour les mineurs une admonestation le
sursis ne serait-ce que le sursis et c
'est pas des peines alors moi je suis
désolé mais on est dans une démocratie
où c'est le législateur qui fait la loi
et les peines et à un éventail des
peines en france comme dans tous les
autres pays d'europe qui permet
d'appliquer un principe constitutionnel
qui s'appelle l'individualisation de la
peine alors on va pas parler de grands
principes
on va parler de pratiques quand vous
avez puisque c'est notre sujet par
exemple une agression de policiers dont
des violences ou un outrage ou une
rébellion
vous devez quand vous êtes magistrat
faire la différence entre un alcoolique
ou un toxicomane qui va se débattre
parce qu'il ne veut pas être interpellé
et quelqu'un qui va sciemment
effectivement jeté un cocktail molotov
sur un policier s'est pas du tout pareil
est évident la peine prononcée et ça
c'est l'existence même des juges que
alliance met en cause la peine prononcée
elle va être adapté à la situation à
l'infraction à sa gravité
et puis évidemment la personnalité de
l'auteur donc quand vous avez je
reprends mon exemple bon
un alcoolique qui va se débattre parce
qu'il veut pas être interpellé contre un
policier
bien sûr vous n'avez vous n'allez pas
comme juge prononcé du tout la même
peine si la personne par exemple a
accepté ensuite des soins pour soigner
son alcoolisme etc
vous allez par exemple effectivement m
le cas échéant une peine de sursis mise
à l'épreuve pour lui dire allez vous
soigner en alcoologie voyez c'est ça le
l'existence même d'un juge c'est fait
pour ça est ce que je vois c'est que ben
finalement pour certains politiques et
certains syndicats de policiers il n'y a
pas d'autres peines possibles que la
prison en plus la prison l'a dit
monsieur monsieur boere a tout à fait
souligné bat les condamnations sans
doute plus en plus d'une heure a
notamment en comparution immédiate mais
les autres peines sont efficaces aussi
on va pas aller sur des questions
criminologique mais on sait très bien
que par exemple des peines comme le
sursis mise à l'épreuve comme le travail
d'intérêt général sont des peines
extrêmement efficace quand les gens sont
bien prises en charge et qu' ils
comprennent le sens de cette peine c'est
beaucoup plus efficace pour la récidive
que la prison encore faut-il du
personnel pour ça et on a les mêmes
problèmes dans la justice que dans la
police qu'est ce que vous voulez quand
un juge de l'application des peines hui
300 dossiers etc un conseiller
d'insertion et de probation suis 100
personnes en même temps
comment voulez vous qu'une peine de
sursis mise à l'épreuve par exemple qui
peut prévoir des soins qui peut prévoir
l'interdiction d'aller dans certains
endroits
qui peut prévoir l'obligation d'avoir
une formation ou un travail bref toute
chose qui permette de réinsérer la
personne condamnée
évidemment quand il ya énormément de
gens qui doivent être suivi par un
conseiller d'insertion et de probation
la mesure est pas du tout si efficace
que si on avait les moyens et le temps
mais encore une fois penser que la
prison est la seule
impossible je crois que c'est mettre en
cause aussi le législateur qui a prévu
tout un éventail comme dans plein
d'autres pays d'europe bien sûr leur
réponse de david aurait verdi les
problèmes de la police et la justice ou
bien c'est la loi
ou bien ces législateurs ou bien c'est
les juges qui font parce qu'on aurait ni
où je vous disais que c'est le conseil
constitutionnel qui vient de retoquer
plusieurs articles du projet de loi de
sécurité globale ou bien c'est carrément
l'état de droit non j'ai juste envie de
vous dire qu'il n'ya pas plus sourd que
celui qui veut pas entendre
on n'a jamais dit qu'il fallait mettre
tout le monde en prison je n'en a jamais
dit que la prison était la solution
miracle à tout ce qui se passe dans la
société
absolument pas nous ce que l'on demande
ceux ci étaient des peines minimales
incompressibles pour les gens qui
agressent les policiers les gendarmes
les pompiers pourquoi pas les maires
parce qu'aujourd'hui les représentants
de communaux elles ont les maires sont
également victimes de violences et
aujourd'hui ce que l'on dit c'est que
pour ces gens ses agresseurs là il n'y
ait pas de remises de peine il n'y est
pas il y était quasiment à coup sûr de
la prison au bout on ne manque pas de la
prison pour l'ensemble des faits qui
sont portés à la connaissance de la
justice bien évidemment que non ce qu on
veut juste être protégés parce
qu'aujourd'hui les policiers nous ne
supportons plus d'aller au travail le
matin ne pas savoir dans quel état va
rentrer le soir on ne sait pas dans quel
état va rentrer le soir et si on va
rentrer vivant c'est ça le problème de
la police aujourd'hui c'est ça le
problème des gens qui sont les
représentants et les garants de
l'autorité de l'état dans ce pays c'est
que on ne sait pas les pots les gens les
pompiers sont à gruissan les pompiers
sont escortés par des policiers quand
ils viennent sauver des vies vous croyez
que c'est normal donc le problème encore
une fois ce n'est pas de mettre tout le
monde en prison c'est de mettre les
agresseurs des gens qui représente
l'autorité de l'état en prison et ça que
ce soit fait et écrit et s'assoit heures
réellement est effectivement appliqué
michel kokoreff
je vais pas reprendre la même
démonstration parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'elle a pas été à l'appel
a été entendu mais encore une fois on
voit bien que il n'ya pas de sou
pénalisation mais il ya plutôt une sur
pénalisation des agresseurs des forces
de l'ordre et depuis un certain temps et
que d'un autre côté
effectivement les risques pris par les
forces de l'ordre
son passé à peu près de 22% dans la
période des années 70 à 6 % dans la
période 2015-2020 donc de quoi on parle
sinon que bon on sent bien qu'il ya un
effet de dramatisation de nous vivons
dans une société qui serait ou la
violence très désinhibé où tout le monde
serait agressé bon voilà on reconnaît là
quand même un bon vieux thème mais moi
ce qui me frappe c'est quand même c'est
ces deux choses c'est que d'un côté
d'une certaine manière ce débat on est
un peu l'indicateur on est en train de
ramener la police via son syndicat
majoritaire et et qui est quand même
voilà bien situer politiquement on en
reparlera peut-être sur le dos de la
justice pour expliquer comment la
justice doit doit procéder et donc
éventuellement de ce n'est pas du tout
un débat sur la police qu'on a
actuellement c'est un débat sur comment
doit fonctionner la justice bon pour
qu'elles soient plus sévères alors que
encore une fois les ailes et allaient
déjà bon
donc c'est ça qui est inquiétant c'est
c'est la façon dont il ya le principe de
séparation des pouvoirs est remis en
cause bon et que tout ça se passe encore
une fois sous avec le soutien notamment
du ministre de l'intérieur bon et en
même temps le soutien d'une partie de la
classe politique mais d'un autre côté ce
qui est frappant c'est que en mettant le
projecteur sur une justice qui sait ce
qui serait décidément en dessous tout un
bon d'un autre côté on voit s'accumuler
les dénis c'est à dire que béni des
violences policières
est ce qu'on parle des éborgné des mains
arrachées des blessés graves à la tête
des morts pendant la période des gilets
jaunes est ce qu'on parle
de tout ce qu'on a pu documenter bon et
qui est encore une fois l'objet d'un
déni
voilà au plus haut niveau de l'état mais
par ailleurs aussi dans les syndicats
majoritaires
est ce qu'on parle du
de la situation qui est faite aux
policiers qui viennent qui ne sortent de
leur école et qui effectivement et c'est
un c'est pas un avis de militants ou de
citoyens je pense que c'est un constat
qui est largement fait soit absolument
pas formés pour affronter les situations
qui se présentent à eux
donc est ce qu'on parle de ces deux ces
conditions de travail n'ont pas vraiment
ça semble pas intéresser pas plus que la
formation en général où le turn-over de
l'encadrement les syndicats bon et là
effectivement en tout cas ce qu'on
entend il ya un décalage
et puis est ce qu'on parle non pas des
15 ou 20
membres de forces de l'ordre qui sont
décédés en service mais est ce qu'on
parle des trente à soixante policiers
qui sont qui commettent un suicide qui
met fin à leurs jours avec leur leur
arme de service man et alors c'est
évidemment pas le seul problème mais il
me semble que cet indicateur de suicides
des policiers il dit quelque chose d'un
malaise policier qui pour autant ne se
retrouvent pas voilà dans les propos
encore une fois très politique
deux sets de 7 de cette manifestation
alors et j'ajoute pour aller quand même
aller long distance du syndicat de la
magistrature c'est que on sait bien que
la prison n'est pas une solution
foucault l'avait très bien montré
l'école de la délinquance voilà ce
qu'est la prison bon et donc quand même
qu'on entende et qu'on dise que il ya eu
un million trois cent mille décisions
qui n'ont pas pu être
réaliser parce qu'il n'ya pas assez de
place dans les prisons alors qu'on est
dans une situation depuis 20 ans de
suroccupation pénal de la france est
pointée du doigt par un certain nombre
d'organisations pente à l'état de
dégradation et d'insalubrité d'un
certain nombre de maisons d'arrêt bon on
croit on croit un peu rêver non la
solution n'est pas la prison elle l'est
pour en tout cas une partie minoritaire
puisqu'on sait que le taux de récidive
et de multirécidive est très important
est bon et donc si on prend pas un peu
en compte tous les constats qu'on a pu
faire sur à la fois le la marche
d'efficacité et en même temps la marge
des chèques de l'institution carcérale
est donc aussi bien au canada en
belgique ou dans d'autres pays anglo
saxons bon effectivement on peut
réinventer à chaque fois le fil à couper
le beurre ou là ou là où la poudre mais
je suis désolé de le dire encore une
fois on est dans l'idéologie
alors je donnerai la parole à david
reverdy mai mais d'abord la mort au nom
mais moi je ne peux pas arbitré un débat
entre idéologues sociologue voilages
j'entends bien la posture de mon
collègue mais il est assez loin de la
neutralité a su axiologique et donc j'ai
rien à en dire je suis pas commentateurs
de deux commentaires on sait bien on
sait bien on sait pas grand chose en
matière de référence et de récidive je
pense le renvoyer vers son connecteur
victor tournier qui a beaucoup mieux
écrit sur ce sujet a dit compris sur
l'indigence de l'outil statistique
disponible mais puisqu'on parlait tout à
l'heure de chiffre je voudrais mettre
des humains derrière les chiffres
voilà la dernière fois qu'on a à peu
près calculer les choses il ya eu vingt
mille trois cent six policiers et
gendarmes qui ont été blessés dans le
cadre de leurs activités c'est pour
répondre à votre question aussi en
mission ou en service dix mille d'entre
eux ont été blessés en mission
ce nombre augmente en moyenne de 15 à
20% par an
neuf mille cinq cents policiers et
gendarmes ont été blessés ou s'être
blessé en service la moitié des
gendarmes ont été blessés
consécutivement à une agression chiffre
en augmentation de 20% quand dans la
police ce chiffre a été en augmentation
de 60%
donc nous parlons du mains d'individus
et donc il s'agit pas de se noyer dans
des éléments statistiquement instable
mais des dures réalités de la vie et
d'ailleurs il ya un deuxième élément qui
permet de vérifier salle qui ne sont pas
les chiffres de la police
mais ceux des hôpitaux et des urgences
donc je crois que il faut se remettre
simplement dans un position assez simple
qui est que pour que les policiers
redeviennent des gardiens de la paix il
faut on est plusieurs dans le jeu ils
sont pas tous tout seul il faut aussi
que leur arrivée dans les territoires ne
se traduise pas par la bande d'en face
mais par le fait qu'ils sont les
dépositaires de la paix publique et que
la manière d'oublier en matière
systématique
la question des autres professions nos
policière et non gendarmique c'est à
dire notamment des pompiers qui vise à
ne pas prendre en compte le niveau
d'agressivité vis-à-vis de tout
opérateur public représentant d'une
mission de service public sur un certain
nombre de territoires enseignants et
magistrats médecins et infirmières
pompiers et policiers
ghazi les postiers agents publics élus
locaux compris est une négation de la
réalité
voilà et il faut faire attention
il ya toujours un moment où le réel
revient il revient brutalement il
revient bruyamment et le négationnisme
même de bonne composition ce trans
provoque en général l'effet exactement
inverse à celui recherché
il faut comprendre écouter entendre et
ne pas nier ce que sont les réalités
après il faut les remettre à niveau et
je le redis il n'y a pas un problème de
policiers il n'y a pas un problème de
gendarmes n'y a pas un problème de
magistrats il ya un problème de
législateurs et de capacité à ce que
nous
ensemble nous créions une politique
pénale qui ressemble à quelque chose et
pour l'instant on en est très loin sur
les mineurs sur la consommation de
stupéfiants sur les missions qui sont
donnés à la police et à ma connaissance
c'est encore le gouvernement et le
président de la république qui a
expliqué alors que une extraordinaire
mission de l'assemblée nationale venait
de réussir quelque chose de quasiment
inédit en france depuis longtemps se
dire parler intelligemment de la
question du trafic et de la consommation
des stupéfiants vient au lieu d'entendre
ça dit m and yet donc moi je suis pour
aller acheter du pâté en croûte chez le
boucher charcutier et d'écouter les
parlementaires quand ils font bien leur
travail
david aurait vers des voix en réaction
par rapport à odos gothisme la de
monsieur le sociologue militants c'est
vrai que de nier la réalité celle que
l'on vit j'ai l'impression qu'on ne vit
pas dans le même monde est content
fréquentent pas les mêmes rues ou les
mêmes villes temps la société est
devenue violente extrêmement violente
les violences faites aux personnes ne
cesse d'exploser celle aux policiers
également monsieur bauer l'a rappelé est
très justement 15 à 20 % d'augmentation
tous les ans deux policiers blessés et
ça c'est vrai c'est insoutenable et il
faudrait
et réfléchir discuter avec les autorités
judiciaires
sachez qu'on a demandé à maintes reprise
avec la précédente garde des sceaux
madame b to b
mais également avec monsieur dupont
moretti au l'actuelle garde des sceaux à
pouvoir les rencontrer à pouvoir
discuter
jamais jamais on a pu les recevoir je
pense qu également les syndicats de la
magistrature n'ont pas plus de chance
que discuter avec leur garde des sceaux
est ce qui est bien dommage parce que
les problématiques de la justice
aujourd'hui la justice que je vous
rappelle est au sommet de la pyramide et
de la chaîne pénale
si la justice dysfonctionne et elle a
des problèmes et ça aurait été bien que
des syndicats de la magistrature puisse
connaître les problématiques de la
justice comme nous nous faisons au sein
du ministère de l'intérieur au sein de
la police nationale parce que personne
ne casse la poule la poussière sous le
tapis
dans notre institution et encore moins
le syndicat alliance donc on aurait aimé
un constat un constat des problématiques
et que l'on puisse discuter alors demain
c'est vrai a lieu le bobo sur l'autorité
judiciaire c'était le huitième péchés
capitaux que l'on avait demandé et
c'était les sept premiers été fait par
notre ministre de l'intérieur sur les
problématiques de la justice n'en
déplaise à monsieur le sociologue qui
pensaient que pour nous tout allait bien
non effectivement nous avons des
problèmes vous avez raison monsieur de
le rappeler des problèmes de formation
des problèmes de management des
problèmes de matériel des problèmes
humains oui c'est une réalité mais nous
le disons nous le crillon oui il y a des
problèmes il faut les régler et le 8e
péché capital c'était celui de
l'autorité judiciaire parce
qu'aujourd'hui l'autorité judiciaire
dysfonctionne et s'il n'y a pas des
syndicats de police pour dire que ça
dysfonctionne si alliance police
nationale ne tire pas la sonnette
d'alarmé avec cette phrase choc
bah je pense qu'on en serait resté dans
le même merdier permettez moi
l'expression est bien lesté mission se
termine le temps imparti est déjà
dépassée je vous remercie tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
m